RESPONSE TO THE COVERED
NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT NON
ESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES AND
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY A
JUDGE ADJUSTMENT TO NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS WE ARE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARINGS HERE IN THE
CAPITAL WITH SOME MEMBERS ABLE
TO PARTICIPATE REMOTELY TODAY
HOWEVER ALL MEMBERS OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE WILL BE HERE IN
THE HEARING ROOM. THOSE
PROVIDING TESTIMONY BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE TODAY ARE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY. FOR OUR
REMOTE PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MOVE
MUTE YOUR PHONES OR COMPUTERS
THIS WILL GREATLY AID IN
ELIMINATE ELIMINATING ANY
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. I ASK THAT
EVERY TIME YOU WISH TO BE
RECOGNIZED THAT YOU USE THE
RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURE IN THE
PRO. HE TIME ARE. TO SPEAK A
POP UP WINDOW WILL ASK IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO IN. MUTE PLEASE A
NEW BEFORE YOU BEGIN SPEAKING.
R. I. T. PERSONNEL WILL PUT YOU
BACK ON MUTE. WHEN YOU. BERMAN
SELLOUT. AND WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WITH SWITCHING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT. THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON
OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. IT WILL
BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND
I WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PERSON PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. TWO TWO SIX
EIGHT ONE FIVE TWO AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. TWO ZERO THREE
ONE EIGHT ONE ZERO. FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW
THE TELECONFERENCE ISTOM WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE. AND
OR THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU MUST MUTE
THE DEVICE YOU ARE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY AND ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO IS DESTRUCTIVE AND I DON'T
EXPECT ANYBODY TO BE. MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE HEARING
SERVICE OUR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WELL EVERY
EVER EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS.
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS IN AS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER. AS
WAS CUSTOMARY THERE MAY BE SOME
LAG TIME FOR PARTICIPANTS WHO
ARE ADJUSTING TO THE NEW USE
ONLINE TOOLS OR TECHNOLOGIES.
PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL AND
PATIENT SO ALL INTERESTED
PARTIES CAN BE HEARD. BEFORE WE
BEGIN LET'S ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
MR HACKER PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CABALLERO HERE NIELSEN KAMLAGER
HERE. VERY GOOD. WE DO HAVE A
QUORUM. TODAY'S HEARING WILL
COER THE SENATE BUILDING BACK
BOLDLY BUDGET PROPOSALS RELATED
TO HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS AS
WELL AS THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
OF PLANNING AND RESEARCH AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT. ALL VOTE
INCLUDING THE VOTE ONLY ISSUES
WILL BE TAKEN AT THE END OF THE
HEARING ONCE WE HAVE COMPLETED
ALL DISCUSSION ITEMS AND HEARD
FROM THE PUBLIC. HOWEVER I WANT
TO NOTE UP FRONT THAT I HAVE
CONCERNS WITH ISSUE NUMBER TWO.
JUST TRANSITION ROAD MAP. AS
SUCH I AM PULLING THIS ISSUE
AND WE WILL NOT BE VOTING ON IT
TODAY. PERFECT TIMING. WE'RE
JUST GETTING STARTED CENTER NAY
NIELSEN WELCOME AND I WAS JUST
GOING TO ASK IF YOU HAD ANY
QUESTIONS OR ANYTHING TO ADD
BEFORE WE BEGIN NOT AT ALL
THANK YOU THANK YOU SENATOR
SENATOR COME UNDER. I JUST WANT
TO SAY THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND THIS IS MY FIRST- AND
MEETING HERE ON THIS COMMITTEE.
AND I WILL ALSO BE DOING DOUBLE
DUTY TODAY BECAUSE I HAVE
RULES- AT THE SAME TIME AND SO-
BUT PLEASE DON'T ANYONE
MISREPRESENT MY- ABSENCES BE
NOT BEING IN- FULLY ACTIVE LEAD
LISTENING AND PARTICIPATING IN
THIS DISCUSSION TODAY. VERY
GOOD WELL WELCOME TO THE
SUBCOMMITTEE WERE SO HAPPY TO
SEE YOU HERE AND WE UNDERSTAND
THE DOUBLE DUTY SUFFERED
THERE'S NO ABSOLUTELY NO NO
PROBLEM. NOW LET'S BEGIN THE
HEARING. AS WE ARE TAKING
ACTION AT THE END OF THE
HEARING WE WILL SKIP THE VOTE
ONLY ITEMS AND BEGIN DISCUSSION
WITH THE SENATE. THE SENATE
BUDGET PLAN ON HOMELESSNESS AND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. WE'RE GOING
TO START WITH ISSUE NUMBER FIVE
WHICH IS THE SENATE PRIORITY
HALL HOMELESS HOMELESSNESS
PACKAGE. AND I'D LIKE TO ASK
THE L. A- IF YOU WOULD BEGIN
THE PRESENTATION. AFTERNOON
THIS IS LUIS MORALES WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
OUR OFFICE HAS BEEN ASKED TO
PRESENT THE SENATE DEMOCRATS. A
BUDGET PLAN AT THIS HEARING AND
I'LL BE DESCRIBING THE PLAN AS
PRESENTED IN YOUR AGENDA. I'M
HAPPY TO TAKE ANY MORE
QUESTIONS AND I'LL DO MY BEST
TO ADDRESS THEM HOWEVER I WILL
BE LIMITED MY ABILITY TO
ADDRESS THE PLAN IN ANY DETAILS
BEYOND WHAT IS. AVAILABLE IN
YOUR MATERIALS. SO BEGIN WITH
ISSUE FIVE WHICH IS THE SENATE
PRIORITY HOMELESSNESS PACKAGE
THE SENATE PLAN INCLUDES FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS OVER FIVE YEARS
FOR A VARIETY OF PROGRAMS
DESIGNED TO END THE STATE'S
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS. IN REDUCE
THE NUMBER OF HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS IN THE STATE THE
PLAN INCLUDES FOUR MAIN
COMPONENTS. FUNDING AND AT THE
FUNDING OF THE ACQUISITION AND
REHABILITATION OF. MULTI FAMILY
PROPERTIES IN ORDER TO CONVERT
THOSE PROPERTIES TO PERMANENT
HOUSING FOR HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS ACROSS THE STATE.
PROVIDING MULTI YEAR SUPPORT
FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
PROVIDE TRANSITION SERVICES FOR
THOSE EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS.
TO EXIT INTO PERMANENT HOUSING.
WAITING FOR AND LET MONTH'S
RENT A LIST. AND PROVIDING.
MULTILAYER FLEXIBLE FUNDING FOR
HOMELESSNESS PROGRAMS THAT
SERVE PEOPLE PARTICIPATING IN
SOME OF THE STATE'S HUMAN
SERVICES PROGRAMS. AND SO THAT
THE NATURAL DISCOURAGE SORT OF
FORMING COMPONENTS OF THE
SENATE HOMELESSNESS PACKAGE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
DOES THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
HAVE ANY COMMENT. THIRTY
THOMPSON APARTMENT OF FINANCE
HAPPEN TO REVIEW THE DETAILS OF
THE PROPOSAL. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- WE WILL NOW OPEN THE
DISCUSSION TO QUESTIONS FROM
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AND
I'D LIKE TO START START OFF-
MYSELF WITH IT WITH THE NUMBER
OF QUESTIONS- AND ACTUALLY JUST
UP POINTS I'D LIKE TO MAKE I
HAD A QUESTION- ABOUT.
OBTAINING DATA FROM- ALL OF THE
EFFORTS THAT KEEP IN THE
HALFPIPE EFFORTS WE'VE MADE TO
REDUCE HOMELESSNESS AND- MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THE
DEPARTMENT- SIX SIX WELL
ACTUALLY IT'S THE UNDER THE
AUSPICES OF THE BUSINESS
CONSUMER SERVICES AND HOUSING
AGENCY THERE IS A HOMELESS
COORDINATING FINANCING COUNCIL
AND- AND THEY HAVE DEVISED A
PORTALS- IN ORDER TO BE ABLE TO
START CAPTURING DATA ON. WHAT
THE SUCCESS OR LACK OF IT. AS
ENTITIES HAVE STARTED DOING
THEIR THEIR HOMELESS- CALORIES
AND- OFFERING SERVICES THAT WE
PUT OUT A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
MONEY OVER THE PAST COUPLE
BUDGET CYCLES. IN EXCESS OF A
BILLION DOLLARS AND I WONDER IF
SOMEBODY- FROM. B. C. S. NH IS
BASED ON THE LINE TO TALK TO US
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THIS PORTAL
BECAUSE I THINK THIS IS GOING
TO BE REALLY IMPORTANT TO BE
ABLE TO DOCUMENT. HOW ARE WE
DOING AND WHAT COMMUNITIES HAVE
DONE A GOOD JOB. AND AND ARE WE
ALLOCATING THE MONEY TO THE
RIGHT TO THE RIGHT AT ENTITIES
WITHIN THE DIFFERENT COUNTIES.
I'M IS THERE SOMEONE ON THE
LINE THAT CAN- TALK TO US A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE HOMELESS
DATA INTEGRATION SYSTEM. HELLO
THIS IS ALEX HODINKEE SECRETARY
FOR HOMELESSNESS OVER AT
DISNEY'S CONSUMER SERVICES I
THINK AGENCY CAN YOU ALL HEAR
ME OKAY WE CAN WE CAN SEE YOU
KNOW THANK YOU SO MUCH HEY. THE
HOBBIT INTERVIEW ONE I AM ARE
REALLY OF THE- INTEGRATIONS.
MIGHT HAVE WENT LIVE JUST LAST
MONTH. IT IS JUST THE TIP OF
THE ICEBERG WHAT WE RELEASED
THERE IS QUITE A BIT AND DATA
TO BE ANALYZED AND EVALUATED
THEIR AND I WOULD IMAGINE IT'S
NOT JUST- THOSE THAT ARE
SEARCHING STATE FUNDING
PROGRAMS BUT ALSO LOCAL AND
FEDERAL FUNDING SO IT ALLOWS US
TO REALLY GREAT. SORT OF MY
FULLER PICTURE. PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS AND
THE SERVICES THAT OUR SEATING
UNTIL YOU ADD SOME INFORMATION
IN THERE AND THAT WE'RE WORKING
VERY QUICKLY TO TRY TO ANALYZE.
AROUND HE BEHALF AND WE ARE
WORKING TO TRY TO WORK WITH
ENERGY DEPARTMENT UNITED HIDE
AT THE BATTLE FROM THERE
FUNDING PROGRAMS AND THE NUMBER
OF FOLKS THAT THEY HAVE
SERVICE. I'M AND ANY ARE
EXPECTING IT THAT IS THAT KIND
OF THING MANY SHY. ASK AND CAN.
AS WE GET GOING I WILL SAY- BUT
BUSINESS ITSELF IS REALLY. TEN
TO BE A- TRACKING. SYSTEM HAVE
OTHER. OTHER TRACKING. FOR
KEEPING HER AROUND AND I'M JUST
FINDING IS BEING. ON LEADS. AND
THIS IS MUCH ABOUT THAT. THE
FOLKS THAT ARE SERVER AND WHAT
HALF TìM THEY MOVED IS. VERY
MUCH AT PERFORMANCE TOOL. AND
TO YOUR- AND VERY MUCH
SOMETHING THE WHOLE. AND HOW
THAT ARE. WHAT WE- OUT AND- HOW
IT WOULD BE SPENDING ARE
FINDING WILL BE ABLE. AND I
ENSURING THAT IT IS USED IN THE-
IN THE PAST MOST. WAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THAT AND I. WAS
NOT LOOKING FOR A FINANCE TOLL
I WAS LOOKING MORE FOR A- A
SUCCESS- FOUR EIGHT. I'M A TOOL
TO EVALUATE- MAYBE. BASED ON
REGION WHO'S. DOING A GOOD JOB-
THIS IS THE ISSUE OF HOME. IS
NUMBER. ISSUE PEOPLE ARE. WITH
ONLY. ALL OVER THIS. IT DOESN'T
IT'S NOT. THAT ONE REGION THAT
SUFFERING. THE IMPACTS OF THE
HOME OF THE HOMELESS POPULATION
IT'S THE NTIRE STATE. AND AS
WE PUT MONEY OUT THE QUESTION
THAT'S BEEN RAISED TO ME. IS
THE APPROPRIATE RECEIVER OF THE
MONEY THE COCS IS IT THE
COUNTIES OR IS IT THE CITIES OR
A COMBINATION OF ALL OF THE
ABOVE I'VE GOT A NUMBER OF
MARES COMPLAINING THAT THEY
DON'T SEE ANY OF THE RESOURCES
IN THE COMMUNITY. MUERTES AND
THEN- AS I'VE ASKED FOR DATA
FROM THE COCS. BOB IT HAS NOT
BEEN FORTHCOMING SO I HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT CONTINUING TO
FIND. ORGANIZATIONS THAT MAY
NOT BE RESPONSIVE IN IN TERMS
OF TELLING US WHAT THEY'RE
DOING WITH THE RESOURCES. ARE
THEY GETTING PEOPLE OFF THE
STREETS WHAT ARE SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT THEY'VE SEEN.
AND AND HOW WHAT KIND OF
SERVICES ARE THEY OFFERING AND
ARE THERE SOME BUT BEST
PRACTICES SO I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE FRAMEWORK I
THINK IT'S GOING TO GIVE US.
SOME OF THE DATA AND- AND IN IN
UP UP IN ADDITION TO THAT ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT I DO WANT TO
SEE IN THIS PARTICULAR. AREA IS
THAT. IF WE CONTINUE TO FIND
THE COCS THEY ARE A CREATION OF
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND AS
SUCH THEY DON'T NECESSARILY
HAVE TO ABIDE BY. BUT THE RULES
THE GOVERNMENT DOES SUCH AS
OPEN MEETING LAWS POSTING THE
AGENDAS CONFLICTS OF INTERESTS
SOME OF THE COCS. ARE MADE UP
OF MEMBERS WHO RECEIVE THE
MONEY AND MOUNTAINS THAT'S THAT
WOULD BE PROHIBITED ANY OF OUR
ENVIRONMENT AND SO. I JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE THAT AS WE
CONTINU TO FUND THESE PROGRAMS
AND TO SET UP. THE THIS THAT
THE INFRASTRUCTURE TO DO IT
THAT WE MAKE SURE THERE'S
TRANSPARENCY. THAT THE
ACCOUNTABILITY AND- AND THE OP
FOR THE TO KNOW WHERE THE MONEY
GOING. FOR THE TO PART IN
MEETINGS ABOUT THE AS WELL SO
THOSE ARE THOSE THAT THAT I
HAVE SOME OF WANNA. MAKE SURE
WE- I THINK THAT- AND THEN LAST-
ISSUE IN THIS THIS- THE KEEPER
THE KEY. OUR RESOURCES HAVE
BEEN TERM- THE ABILITY TO
PURCHASE EXISTING INFO ON
HOTELS AND MOTELS AND THEN USE
IT TO HOUSE THE HOMELESS IS
REALLY IMPORTANT BUT I WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE SOME-
THE ABILITY TO. KEEP THOSE
UNITS AFFORDABLE THAT THAT IF
THE MONEY DRIES UP SME SOME
SOMETIME ALONG THE LINE WHETHER
IT'S STATE REVENUES OR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT REVENUES THAT THE
HOUSING THAT HAS BEEN PURCHASE
STAYS AFFORDABLE AND IN THE
PUBLIC SPHERE SO THAT WE DON'T
LOSE THE AFFORDABILITY AND THE
ABILITY TO USE THOSE THOSE-
THOSE ARE- UNITS SO THERE HAVE
TO BE COVENANTS THAT PROTECT
THAT AND I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE BUILDING IT IN ANY
SYSTEM SO. THAT A LOT OF A LOT
OF ISSUES THERE BUT I THINK
FROM. THAT THE REALLY IMPORTANT
THING IS TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
THE RESOURCES SO WE CAN. WE CAN
GET THE UNITS WE DESPERATELY
NEED. THAT'S IT FOR ME SENATOR
NIELSEN. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
YOU'RE CERTAINLY DID PROVOKE A
LOT OF INTEREST IN ME WITH YOUR
REMARKS RIGHT NOW. I'VE DEALT
WITH THIS ISSUE FOR AN AWFUL
LOT OF YEARS AND I HAVE LIKE
AND HOW CALIFORNIA. AND I THINK
MANY OTHER STATES AS WELL ABOUT
WITHTHE HOMELESS POPULATION
IT'S LIKE AN ABSTRACT ARTIST.
WE GET A BIG WHITE CREATED WALL.
BRING IN A BUCKET OF PAINT THE
WHAT BRUSHING GOES SPORTFISHING
IT AGAINST THE WALL. I THINK
THAT'S BEEN FOOLHARDY IN FACT
I'M GOING NOW EVEN FURTHER I
BELIEVE THAT IN TERMS OF OUR
HOMELESS POPULATION WE SHOULD
BEGIN ASSESSING THE
INDIVIDUAL'S NEEDS AS WE DO IN
THE SCHOOL THE I. E. P.
INDIVIDUAL EDUCATION PLAN WHAT
ARE THE NEEDS OF THAT HOMELESS
POPULATION PROVIDING A SHELTER.
A PLACE TO SLEEP IS NOT
SUFFICIENT. OTHER THAN TO KEEP
THEM IN THAT STATE. I WOULD
RATHER SEE THEM BE ABLE TO
TRANSITION. INTO A MORE
PERMANENT STATE OF
SURVIVABILITY. AND I DON'T KNOW
THAT WE'RE PROGRAMS HAVE BEEN
ALL THAT SUCCESSFUL IN DOING IT.
AND I WOULD GO ALL THE WAY BACK
TO THE GAME PROGRAM WHICH NOW
HAS BEEN FOR MANY YEARS CALLED
CAL WORKS. IT WAS A HISTORIC
CHANGE IN WELFARE REFORM THE
SAME KIND OF PRINCIPLE WOULD
APPLY HERE. WORK ADDRESSING
NEEDS OF THE INDIVIDUALS NOT
JUST WHERE THEY SLEEP. AND NOT
EVEN JUST WHERE THEY EAT. BUT
HOW DO THEY SURVIVE. AND I'LL
TELL YOU MAYBE SOME PEOPLE
DON'T MIND LIVING ON THE
STREETS ON THE RIVER BANKS. BUT
I THINK THAT WE FOR THEM AND
THEY THEMSELVES CAN DO BETTER.
AND THAT GOVERNS MY THINKING AS
WE DEAL WITH THESE ISSUES THANK
YOU MANAGER. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SENATOR NELSON- THIS ITEM
IS A HOLD OPEN SO WILL NOW MOVE
TO THE NEXT ITEM ON THE AGENDA
WHICH IS ISSUE NUMBER SIX.
SENATE PRIORITY CALIFORNIA
DREAM FOR ALL FIRST TIME HOME
BUYERS PROGRAM. WOULD LIKE TO
ASK THE L. A- IF THEY WOULD
PRESENT. YES I BEEN TO ITEM SIX
STILL POINT OF CLARIFICATION I
DON'T FIVE AND MAY HAVE
MISSPOKEN ON THE TALK TALK PLAN
NUMBER IT'S TWENTY BILLION OVER
A FIVE YEAR PERIOD I APOLOGIZE
FOR THAT. AND SO FOR ITEMS SIX-
THIS IS THE SENATE PRIORITY FOR
THE CALIFORNIA DREAM FOR ALL
FIRST TIME HOMEBUYERS PROGRAM.
THE SENATE PLAN PROPOSES
LANGUAGE DIRECTED THE STATE
TREASURER AND THE
ADMINISTRATION TO DEVELOP A
FIRST TIME HOME BUYERS PROGRAM.
IN DETAIL AND 2% THAT PLAN BACK
TO THE LEGISLATURE FOR
IMPLEMENTATION. THROUGH STATUTE
IN TWENTY TWENTY TO. HAPPY TO
TAKE ANY QUESTIONS VERY GOOD
I'D LIKE TO ASK THE- STATE
TREASURER'S OFFICE TO SEE IF
THEY HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR THIS IS TIM SCHAFER
DEPUTY STATE TREASURER CAN YOU
AND THE COMMITTEE HERE ME. OKAY
WE CAN ALL RIGHT THANK YOU FOR
THAT- HI OBVIOUSLY THE
CONCEPTUAL PROPOSAL THAT- YOU
HAVE BEFORE YOU- THENEED SO
GREAT MORE DETAIL TO COMMENT AS
TO THE FINANCIAL OPERATIONS OF
IT. WHAT I WOULD OBSERVE- AS
PART OF THIS OFFICE IS THAT-
THE CALIFORNIA STATE TREASURY
INVESTS BORROWS AND INTERACTS
WITH THE PAYMENT SYSTEM. IN
WAYS THAT MOST OTHER STATE
AGENCIES DO NOT WE WOULD
OBSERVE THAT. I'M DOING THIS
KIND OF PROGRAM. MORE LIKELY
THAN NOT WOOD- B. AFTER YOU
SIGNIFICANT. MANEUVER BY
CALIFORNIA TO ADDRESS IT SAYS A
SHORTAGE OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND WOULD MORE LIKELY THAN NOT
EXTEND WELL BEYOND THE NOTION
OF TAX CREDITS AND OR RETOOLING
OF EXISTING PROGRAMS SUCH AS
THOSE. MADAM CHAIR THAT EXISTED
CAL HFA WHERE- I HAD THE
PLEASURE OF SERVING WITH YOU ON
THE ON THE BOARD A NUMBER OF
YEARS AGO. THE CONCEPT AS I
UNDERSTAND IT FROM. THE SENATE.
IS TO CREATE A HYBRID OF- THE A
SERVICEMAN'S READJUSTMENT ACT
OF NINETEEN FORTY FOUR COMMONLY
KNOWN AS THE GI BILL WHICH IN
ADDITION TO. EDUCATIONAL
BENEFITS ALSO CREATED WHAT WE
NOW KNOW TODAY IS VETERANS
LOANS. SO A VERY INTENSE THAT.
MELDED WITH A PHENOMENON THAT
WE OBSERVE OCCURRED IN THE LATE
SEVENTIES AND NINETEEN EARLY
NINETEEN EIGHTIES WHEN INTEREST
RATES WERE VERY HIGH BACK
FUNDAMENTAL IS KNOWN AS A
SHARED APPRECIATION MORTGAGE.
AND WOULD COUPLE THAT WITH A
PROGRAM OPERATED- PRESENTLY BY-
CAL HSA AND MANY OTHER STATES
IN THE FORM OF DOWN PAYMENT
ASSISTANCE- WE EXPECT THAT- THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF SUCH A
PROGRAM WOULD BE HIGHLY LIKELY
TO REQUIRE THE UNPRECEDENTED
COOPERATION. BETWEEN THE STATE
AND PRIVATE ENTERPRISES TO
AVOID. EXPOSING CALIFORNIA
TAXPAYERS TO SOME OF THE
FINANCIAL RISKS THAT MAY BE
INHERENT WHILE STILL
PRESERVING. THE BENEFITS. TO BE
CLEAR- I AM NOT A MEMBER OF THE
BAR SO I DON'T PRACTICE LAW BUT
I WOULD FULLY EXPECT. THAT
THERE WILL BE MULTIPLE LEGAL
ISSUES THAT WOULD COME BEFORE
THE STATE AND HELPING THIS
PROGRAM- THAT MAY BE BEYOND
STATUTORY MIGHT EVEN BE
CONSTITUTIONAL BUT NEVER THE
LAST. AS I'VE EXPRESSED TO THE
PRO TEM'S OFFICE- AND TO
SEVERAL INDIVIDUAL SENATE
OFFICES. LEAVE THAT THAT IS
NOT- THAT IS NOT A REASON TO-
SUGGESTS THAT THIS IS I'M
DOABLE BUT RATHER TO JUST BE IT
IT SPEAKS FOR A DEGREE OF
CAUTION AND A HIGH DEGREE OF
THOUGHT IN A PROCEEDING WITH
THAT. WHAT WE CAN OBSERVE AS
FINANCIAL PEOPLE IN THE
TREASURER'S OFFICE IS THAT THIS
IS. HIGHLY LIKELY TO PRODUCE
SOME A SIGNIFICANT- IMPROVEMENT
IN THE SUPPLY OF HOUSING IN OUR
STATE IS. THOUGHTFULLY AND
CAREFULLY IMPLEMENTED AND- THE
TREASURE IS LOOKING FORWARD TO
WORKING- WORKING WITH OTHER
OFFICIALS IN THE STATE- TO
STANDING- THE PROGRAM UP AFTER
CAREFUL STUDY THEN I'LL BE
HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS IF YOUR
THE- MERCED THE COMMITTEE HAVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- SURGERIES-
AN ISSUE THAT- I HAD SOME
CONCERN ABOUT- IT'S ALWAYS
HARDER TO STAND UP A NEW
PROGRAM THAN IT IS TO USE ONE
THAT ALREADY EXISTS- ED BAND SO
I'M I'M MINDFUL OF THE. NEED TO
BE CAREFUL WHEN YOU'RE SETTING
UP BUT A NEW PROGRAM THAT IS
THAT IS ROLE WILL ENTAIL AN
INVESTMENT A PRIVATE EQUITY OR
PRIVATE CAPITAL IN ORDER TO GET
IT GOING AND I'M I'M WONDERING-
SINCE YOU HAVE EXPERIENCE WITH-
WITH KELLY CHIPPED A AND WE DID
WE DID SIT ON THE BOARD
TOGETHER AND- AND PART OF THE
REASON THAT CAL HFA DOES DO A
FIRST TIME HOME BUYERS ROGRAM
WAS BECAUSE OF THE ROBUST
CONVERSATION OF THE BOARD. IN
FAVOR OF HOMEOWNERSHIP AND WHAT
WE KNOW IS THAT CALIFORNIA HAS
THE LOWEST. HOME OWNERSHIP RATE.
SINCE THE NINETEEN FORTIES AND
WHAT THAT MEANS IS THAT ALL THE
BENEFITTED THE GI BILL WAS LOST
AFTER WORLD WAR TWO AND SO- WE
WE'VE WE'VE GONE BACKWARDS IN
AND IN THE ABILITY OF PEOPLE TO
BE ABLE TO AFFORD TO OWN A HOME
IN THE STATE AND SO ANYTHING WE
CAN DO. TO CREATE AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR PEOPLE TO GET
INTO THEIR OWN- UNIT WHETHER
IT'S A CONDO OR A TOWNHOUSE OR
AT AN ACTUAL- DETACHED UNIT IS
REALLY IS REALLY REALLY
IMPORTANT THE COST IS THE
BIGGEST OBSTACLE AND THE INCOME
OF THE PURCHASERS IT IS THE
BIGGEST OBSTACLE SO THIS. THIS
CONCEPT IS REALLY A GREAT
CONCEPT BUT COULD YOU TELL ME-
WHAT THE DIFFERENCE WOULD BE
BETWEEN THE CALLOUS YOU'RE FAYE
AND WHITE WHY WOULDN'T WE PUT
THIS ACCOUNT YOUR FAITH IF
THEY'VE GOT A PROGRAM THAT'S
ALREADY. WORKING SHE- WELL I
GUESS I WOULD RESPECT IT THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION MADAM
CHAIR I WOULD- I WOULD LIKE TO
ANSWER THOSE IN REVERSE ORDER-
BUT BUT TO FRAME MY RESPONSES
I'D LIKE TO SAY THIS IS NOT.
THIS IS NOT A PROGRAM THAT THE
STATE TREASURER. SANTA ANA
TERRITORIAL SENSE RATHER HER
DIRECTION TO ME IS PART OF OUR
STAFF IS TO ASSIST WHEREVER
POSSIBLE WITH THE FINANCIAL
ENGINEERING OF IT SO THAT TAKES
ME TO YOUR SECOND QUESTION AND
THAT IS CAL HSA. I SEE NO
REASON WHY THIS COULDN'T
EXISTED CAL H. AT FE I WOULD
OBSERVE. THAT ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT. SHOULD BE LOOKED AT
PRETTY CAREFULLY. IS WHETHER OR
NOT THE ASSETS AND RESOURCES OF
CALAIS TO FADE WOULD BE
EXPOSED. TO ANY INCREMENTAL OR
ADDITIONAL LOST. AS A RESULT OF
THE PROJECT AT THE ENGAGEMENT
OF THE PRIVATE SECTOR- IF THERE
IS A MECHANISM IN PLACE. TO
FIRE WALL THE PUBLIC ASSETS CAL
HFA THEN I WOULD SEE NO REASON
WHY- YOU KNOW THAT THAT
ALTERNATIVE SHOULDN'T BE
IMAGINE. IF ON THE OTHER HAND
THAT BECOMES. TO RESTRICTIVE TO
CUMBERSOME- AND INSTEAD THE
INTENT WOULD BE TO CREATE SOME
DISTANCE BETWEEN THE STATE
ITSELF AND THIS INVESTMENT
ACTIVITY. IT MAY AGUE AGAINST
HAVING IT TO. UNDER THE AGES OF
HAVE KELLY TO SAY LET ME GIVE
AN EXAMPLE. THAT IS THE BEST
EXAMPLE IMPERFECT AS IT MAY BE
IT'S THE BEST EXAMPLE I CAN
GIVE YOU AND THE COMMITTEE. IN
THE DAVIS ADMINISTRATION THERE
WAS THE DECISION MADE TO-
SECURITIZED- INCOMING- TOBACCO
SETTLEMENT REVENUES FROM THE
MASTER SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT
AMONG THE TWENTY FIVE OR TWENTY
SEVENTH ST STE. BUT TO THE FIVE
MAJOR TOBACCO COMPANIES. THIS
REQUIRED THAT THE STATE
ACTUALLY ESTABLISH. A COMPANY
THE GOLDEN STATE TOBACCO
SECURITIZATION CORPORATION. IN
ORDER TO AVOID- POLLUTING IF
YOU WELL- THE STATE'S OWN
BALANCE SHEET WITH. WITH SOME
OF THESE REVENUES. HOW IS
IMPERFECT IS THAT IT MAY BE
THAT IS- I THINK COULD BE A
CLUE TO WHAT MAY BE REQUIRED
HERE IF THAT CAN BE DONE
SUCCESSFULLY WITH CAL HFA.
WITHOUT VIOLATION OF ANY
CONSTITUTIONAL REQUIREMENTS OR
OR CREATING- CRADDICK
IMPEDIMENT TO ACTUALLY GETTING
THE MONEY OUT THE DOOR TO
CALIFORNIANS CERTAINLY AS A
TECHNICAL EXPERT I WOULD HAVE
NO OBJECTION TO THAT BUT I HEAR
YOUR CONCERNS- I SHARE IT AND
HE SIMPLY THINK WE DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH INFORMATION YET BUT I
HOPE I WAS ABLE TO AT LEAST
SATELLITE. YES I THANK YOU FOR
THAT AND I APPRECIATE THE
EXAMPLE THAT YOU GAVE CONSERVE
IT WAS VERY CLEAR THAT PRECIADO
VERY MUCH THANK YOU. SENATOR
NELSON. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
EXCUSE MY FRUSTRATION WHICH
WILL SHOW OVER IN MY
COUNTENANCE BUT THIS IS THIS
NEW INITIATIVE OF THE
MINISTRATION OF STARTING OUT
JUST LIKE MOST EVERYTHING ELSE.
NOT PUT. NOT BREAK NOT FILLED
WITH THE INGREDIENTS NEEDED NOT
WELL THOUGHT OUT. ONE QUESTION
THAT REALLY HOLES IN MY- IN MY
MIND IS THE RULES EQUITY HERE.
AS OUR SECOND MORTGAGE THAT THE
STATE WOULD HOLD OR THE OF THE
FINANCIAL UP AFTER THE WHOEVER
THAT IS WHATEVER BUSINESS WHO
HOLDS EQUITY. WHO DID THEY COME
BACK ON. THE CHURCH CARE
CORRECTLY- CHARACTERIZE WE
DON'T WANT TO SEE THAT- RATHER
THE DEFENSE DEPARTMENT THE
STATE BE THE BEAR THE BURDEN.
BUT ON THE OTHER HAND THE STATE
BEARS A LOT OF RESPONSIBILITY
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WHAT DO I
NEED. BEST EXAMPLE YEARS AGO
NOT MANY A. HA HOMELESS
ADVOCATES PERSON. AIM TO OUR
COMMITTEE. AND WAS JUST SKATING
WAY CONDEMNING. CHECK WHAT.
SAYING YOU KNOW WE COULD BUILD.
SHOCKERS FOR THESE HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS FOR SEVEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS LESS. IF WE WERE ON
BURDEN. FROM THE REGULATIONS.
AND I DON'T THINK ANY OTHER
THING I TO MOVE AHEAD IN THIS
LEGISLATURE WITHOUT SOME KIND
OF REFORM OF THE REGULATORY
PROCESS SEES THE IMPEDE AND
INFLATE ENORMOUSLY. THE COST OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING YOU CANNOT
TALK ABOUT AFFORDABLE HOUSING
WITHOUT DEALING WITH THE
REGULATIONS THAT MAKE THEM.
CHAU ON AFFORDABLE. AND THAT
DOES CONCERN ME. AND A
GENTLEMAN LEGEND OF THE
BUREAUCRATIC. IMPEDIMENTS THEY
ARE SO MANY OF THEM. THEY'RE
ALMOST INVISIBLE. WE'RE NOT
GETTING A RESERVOIRS BUILT
UNDER A BOND THE PAST SEVERAL
YEARS AGO. SIX YEARS LATER.
BUREAUCRATIC IMPEDIMENTS. WE
NEED TO LOOSEN UP ON SOME OF
THAT AND AT LEAST LOOK AT IT
CRITICALLY AND WHENEVER WE'RE
GOING TO AND TRUST SOMEBODY TO
OVERSEE THIS IT MUST BE
RETURNED OVERSEEN AND IT MUST
BE ACCOUNTABLE TO SOMEBODY AND
I WOULD ARGUE THE LEGISLATURE
SHOULD BE THAT ACCOUNTABLE
AUTHORITY AND WE SHOULD BE ABLE
TO ACT. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR- I
SEE NO OTHER QUESTIONS- THIS
ITEM IS A HOLD OPEN ITEM. AND
SO WE'LL MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT
AGENDA ITEM WHICH IS ISSUE
NUMBER SEVEN. THE SENATE
PRIORITY AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PACKAGE AND I'D LIKE TO ASK THE
L. A. OR IF THEY WOULD LIKE TO
PRESENT MR MORALIS. YES THANK
YOU THE SENATE PLAN INCLUDES
SEVERAL COMPONENTS INTENDED TO
CREATE AND PRESERVE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING FOR EXAMPLE
ESTABLISHING FINANCES FINNCING
TOOLS FOR ACCESSORY DWELLING
UNITS CONSTRUCTION PROVIDING
INCENTIVES TO CONVERT VACANT OR
UNDER USED COMMERCIAL AND
RETAIL SPACE INTO AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. AND ASSISTING LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS NONPROFITS AND
OTHER QUALIFIED BUYERS TO
ACQUIRE FORECLOSED HOMES FOR
USE AS HOUSING. HAPPY TO TAKE
ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. I'M ANY
QUESTIONS OF MISS MORALIS ON
THE SIDE OF. YES SENATOR NELSON
I'M SURE I'LL BE VERY BRIEF BUT
UNDERSTAFFED COMMENTS ON ON MY
REPORTS HERE EVERYONE OF THESE
BULLETS SHOULD BE EXAMINED.
INCENTIVES TO CONVERT BACON
NINETY YEARS COMMERCIAL RETAIL
SPACE AND AFFORDABLE HEALTH
OKAY HOW WE'RE GOING TO DO THAT.
THE MERGING GRANTS LOW INCOME
HOMEOWNERS TO AVOID
FORECLOSURE. HOW WE'RE GOING TO
DO THAT WHERE'S THE MONEY GOING
TO COME FROM. FURNISHES
TAXPAYERS AND REALLY FOR
RENTERS. RUN TAX CREDIT FOR
SECOND COME FROM. INCENTIVIZING
EARTHQUAKE RETROFIT FEDERAL 75%
FUNDS OKAY THAT'S SOME FEDERAL
MONEY THERE BUT THE POINT BEING.
THESE THINGS ARE NOT DECIDED
YET AND WHERE WE ARE WELL
THROUGH INTO THE BUDGET PROCESS
FOR THIS YEAR. AND THESE THINGS
AND THESE QUESTIONS ARE ONLY
NOW ASK BY THE CHAIR MYSELF AND
WHATEVER MEMBERS OF YOU KNOW
KIND OF THE COMMITTEES. I THINK
WE'LL GET IN THE CAR WHERE FOR
THE HEAD OF THE COURSE HERE
FORTUNE WE BETTER SLOW DOWN AND
GET IT RIGHT. AND SO FAR IN
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE NOT GOTTEN
DEALING WITH THE HOMELESS RIGHT.
THANK YOU SENATOR SENATOR
NIELSEN- SO MY COMMENT ON THIS
PARTICULAR- ISSUE THIS THIS IS
PART OF THIS SAID SENATE
PRIORITY PACKAGE AND- A NUMBER
OF THESE ARE ARE A RESPONSE. OR
IN RESPONSE TO BILLS THAT
MEMBERS HAVE THAT ARE WORKING
THEIR WAY THROUGH THE
LEGISLATURE RIGHT NOW. WHAT WE
KNOW IS THAT. BEHIND
HOMELESSNESS AS THE NUMBER ONE
ISSUE AMONG CALIFORNIANS IS THE
WHOLE IDEA OF HOUSING. AND I
THINK PEOPLE RECOGNIZE THAT THE
LACK OF AFFORDABLE UNITS. IS
WHAT IT EXACERBATES THE
HOMELESS SITUATION. AND THAT
THE PANDEMIC HAS HAD A
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT IN THAT
REGARD TO AND SO THE MORE UNITS
THAT WE CAN BUILD. THE MORE WE
CAN DEAL WITH. SOME OF THE
ISSUES THAT ARE FACED THAT
REALLY CONTRIBUTED TO THE
CORONA VIRUS. WHAT WE KNOW IS
THAT. THE CORONA VIRUS HAD A
MAJOR IMPACT AND DETRIMENTALLY
AFFECTED FAMILIES THAT LIVED IN
OVERCROWDED HOUSING SITUATIONS
AND THEY'RE LIVING IN
NOT BECAUSE EIGHT. THEY WANT TO
BUT BECAUSE THEY CAN'T AFFORD
TO RENT A UNIT ALL BY
THEMSELVES IN FACT. THEY HAVE
TO RENT A HOUSE OR AN APARTMENT
AND THEN SUBLEASE ROOMS IN THAT
HOUSE OR APARTMENT AS A WAY TO
BE ABLE TO AFFORD THE RENT. FOR
THE MORE UNITS WE CAN GT
BUILT. ON THE BETTER. THE
BETTER OUR COMMUNITIES ARE
GOING TO BE. AND THE LESS
OVERCROWDING WILL HAVE AND- I
DON'T EXPECTED THIS PANDEMIC IS
GOING TO BE THE ONLY ONE THAT
WILL BE FACING IN THE FUTURE SO
WE DESPERATELY NEED TO BUILD.
BILL HOUSING AND WE'RE LOOKING.
EXPEDITING THE OPPORTUNITY
WHETHER IT'S THROUGH EIGHTY USE
ARE USING COMMERCIAL RETAIL
PROPERTY- TRYING TO CREATE
OPPORTUNITIES I THINK THIS IS
IT THIS IS INNOVATIVE AND NOVEL
AND- IT IT DOES NEED SOME MORE
WORK THERE'S NO QUESTION ABOUT
IT BUT AS THESE BILLS WORKED
THEIR WAY THROUGH THE
LEGISLATURE TO HAVE RESOURCES
TO ACTUALLY BRING THEM TO
FRUITION IS GOING TO BE IT'S
GOING TO BE CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT SO I THINK THIS IS A-
REALLY IMPORTANT. REALLY
IMPORTANT ITEM AND WILL
CONTINUE TO HAVE SOME MORE
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT THIS IS A
HOLD OPEN ITEM SO I EXPECT
WE'RE GOING TO SEE THIS BACK
AGAIN SO WE'LL MOVE ON TO THE
NEXT ITEM ON THE AGENDA WHICH
IS THE DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING
AND COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
PROPOSAL ISSUE NUMBER EIGHT.
HOUSING LAW ASSISTANCE AND-
EGGMAN ASK H. CD IF THEY WOULD
LIKE TO PRESENT THIS. HELLO
MAKING ME FROM THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING NEEDS
MADE ABOUT MEANT THAT. HAPPENED
A LOT. OF ALL. AND IT IS A
REQUEST FOR SIX POSITION- GROW
WORKING WE'RE DOING IN THAT
STATE NOW AND WE AND WE HAVE A-
OR AMPLE AREAS HOUSING LAW-
AND- WE START. FRAME TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE BUT WE ARE REALIZING
INCREDIBLY INTENSIVE- WORK AND
WE WANT THAT AND WE ARE NOT
KEEPING UP WITH THE DEMAND AND
WE WANT TO REALLY CONTINUE TO
GROW THAT EXPLOSIVE. AND
SHORTER FICTION BACK BUYING-
WITH ALIVE- GIVE THEM THE TOOLS
TO HELP GET THEM THERE- AND
THAT THIS- REQUEST WILL HAVE A
POINT. WHAT'S THAT THANK YOU.
THANK VERY MUCH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FIND YOU HAVE ANYTHING TO.
DINNERS ARE COMING UP ON ITS NO
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS. BRIGAND
ARMS WILL NOT HAVE A DISCUSSION
OR QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
SENATOR NELSON. IF ONE OF THE
QUESTIONS HERE AGAIN IT'S
ORGANIZATIONAL AND THAT'S
FUNDAMENTAL. AND ALL I SEE HERE.
MORE QUESTIONS. AND FEW MORE
ANSWERS. IS H. THREE D. THE
RIGHT PLACE I DON'T KNOW.
USUALLY WE THROW IT IN SEVERAL
PLACES AND DAVE CONFLICT.
COMPETE OR GET CONFUSED. AND I
SHOOT NO CLARITY HERE WITH THE
HOUSING LAW ASSISTANT- HOW AND
WHAT FORM RESEARCH ASSISTANCE
GOING TO TAKE ARE WE GOING TO
HAVE. REAL ESTATE MINDED PEOPLE
GOING IN AND TALKING TO THE
HOMELESS ABOUT HOW THEY
TRANSITION INTO SOME MORE
PERMANENT HOUSING. OR NO THAT'S
NOT GONNA HAPPEN. IN VERY RARE
CASES BUT HOW THEN THE SUCH A
HOMELESS PERSON TRANSITION TO
PREPARE THEMSELVES TO BE ABLE
OF THAN A CHOIR. THE
DISTRIBUTION EQUITY IN SOME
KIND OF HOUSING STRUCTURE.
AGAIN I THINK WE'RE STILL IN
DOWN THE TRACK OF JUST THROWING
MORE MONEY AT IT AS LONG AS WE
DO THAT I'M GOING TO BE A NO
VOTE. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
THANK YOU SENATOR NIELSEN I'M
JUST THERE BY WAY OF
CLARIFICATION I THINK THIS
PARTICULAR ITEM HAS TO DO WITH
EACH CD. ASSISTING LOCAL
GOVERNMENT- AND- FROM FROM FROM
MY PERSPECTIVE I JUST WANNA.
SAY THAT I APPRECIATE THIS IS A
NEW OFFICE WAS UP. FOR TO READ.
AND IT WAS IT WAS A- SEEN AS A
MEASURE BE USE CONSEQUENCE IN
LOCAL FOR. DOING THEY'RE
SUPPOSED TO- TO PROVIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO BE ABLE
TO GET. THEM TO UNDERSTAND WHAT
STATE LAW IS AND WHAT THEIR
REQUIREMENTS IN A QUICKER
MENTION OBLIGATIONS ARE SO FROM
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE THE
INSTANCE THAT I AM I HAD.
OCCASION TO GET INVOLVED IN WAS
A COMMUNITY WHO HAD APPROVED A
HOUSING PROJECT AND THEN.
BASICALLY DRAG THEIR FEET IN
ISSUING PERMITS AND THEY YOU
KNOW EVERY DELAY. IN ISSUING
PERMITS TIME IS MONEY. AND SO
THEY THEY WERE. THEY WERE BEING
HELD UP. IN THEIR FINAL
OCCUPANCY BECAUSE OF A
DISAGREEMENT OVER A FENCE. AND
THAT'S THE KIND OF THING WHERE
YOU GOT THAT'S MINISTERIAL YOU
MAY WANT TO DO YOU HAVE THE
RIGHT SET BACKS AND EVERYTHING
ELSE JUST GETTING THAT FENCE UP
IS JUST. SHOULDN'T HOLD UP- THE
OCCUPANCY PERMITS AND SO EIGHT
EIGHT CD WAS INVOLVED AND THEY
WERE ABLE TO NEGOTIATE IT I AM.
A AT RETURN TO SANITY IF YOU
WELL AND EVERYTHING WAS ABLE TO
MOVE. THE EXPEDITIOUSLY AND
PEOPLE MOVED INTO THE APARTMENT
THAT THEY DESPERATELY NEEDED
AND THAT THEY HAD BEEN WAITING
FOR SO. SO I REALLY APPRECIATE
TO SIT DOWN AND HAVE A
DISCUSSION ABOUT- ABOUT
APPROVAL APPROVAL OF PROJECTS
AND WHICH REQUIRED AND HOW TO
BE ABLE TO GET TO YES SO THAT.
ONCE ONCE IT AT A LOCAL
GOVERNMENT HAS APPROVED. A
PROJECT OR- ONCE THEY HAVE THE
RULES IN PLACE ABOUT HOW THE
PROJECT SHOULD PROCEED THAT
THEY FOLLOW THOSE RULES THAT'S
REALLY WHAT THIS IS ABOUT IT
SO- I THINK. THIS IS A REAL
IMPORTANT. PROGRAM WITHIN EACH
CD AND I AND I APPRECIATE.
THEIR HARD WORK AND- ONE IS I
WANT TO SUPPORT THEM IN IN IN
THE REQUEST FOR RESOURCES- SO
WHAT WE'RE GOING TO TAKE ACTION
ON THIS ITEM AT THE END OF THE
HEARING- SO WE'LL MOVE ON TO
ISSUE NUMBER NINE WHICH IS THE
INFILL INFRASTRUCTURE
INFRASTRUCTURE PROGRAM
PROPOSITION ONE REALLOCATION.
AND I AGAIN I'D LIKE TO ASK
EACH CD IF THEY'D LIKE TO
PRESENT. GERMANY VERY MUCH GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE. I'M MARK
JEREMY SYSTEM DEPUTY DIRECTOR.
AT THE DIVISION OF FINANCIAL
SYSTEMS AND H. E. B. HCV RISK
THREE HUNDRED MILLION A PROP
ONE FUNDING. WHICH WE'RE
SPLITTING INTO TWO SEPARATE
NOTICE OF FUNDING AVAILABILITY
OUR NUMBERS THE FIRST WORD WE
WANT TO RE APPROPRIATE ONE
HUNDRED SIX MILLION. ATTACHED
FUNDING TO EXTENDING COVERAGE
CURRENT JUNE. TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TO JUNE THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY
TWO. WE ALSO WANT TO
APPROPRIATE ONE HUNDRED TWENTY
FOUR POINT ONE MILLION. AND
THAT'S FUNNY IN THE TWENTY ONE-
I'M BUDGET ACT WITH INCUMBENTS.
THROUGH JUNE THIRTIETH TWENTY
THREE. AT LIQUIDATION DATE OF
JUNE THIRTIETH. ONE TWENTY SIX.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OUR
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ANY
COMMENTS. IT INCREASE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NO
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS. VERY GOOD
I'M BRINGING THE MATTER BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE. SENATOR NELSON
DO YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR
CONCERNS. MOTIVATOR I HARDLY
AGREE WITH YOU. AND I'M VERY
MUCH A LOCAL GOVERNMENT
PERSONAL I NEVER WOULD BLESSED
TO SERVE IN LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
BUT HISTORICALLY THE STATE JUST
DUMP THINGS ON. LOCAL
GOVERNMENT INCLUDING THE
HOUSING PROBLEM HERE IT'S YOURS.
IF THESE AGENCIES OF THE STATE
GOVERNMENT AS WE PROMULGATE
AGENCIES. AS WE DO AND WITH
THIS ONE HERE I EITHER GO WITH
STAFF IT UP IF THE SOME CLEAR
GUIDE. AND SIMPLY READ. THE A-
OF STATE HAD ABIDE BY. AND FOR
SIGNALS AND- ERECTED TO LOCAL.
TO WORK WITH THEM THEN THAT'S
HELPFUL. AND ANOTHER THING THAT
WE HAVEN'T OF OUR COMMUNITY WE
THE NUMBER. YOU KNOW WE WANT TO
HAVE OR FOR- BUT NOW HERE. NOT
IN THIS GALA. I FOUGHT THAT
BATTLE FOR DECADES IN
FARMWORKER HOUSING. WE'RE NOT
NOT MUCH TALKING ABOUT HOW EVEN
IN THE PROPOSED. CERTAIN
CANDIES THAT I READ. ALL WE
YEAH WE'VE GOT A THOSE. IN THE
CAB THE HARVEST ARE. APPS IT-
BUT DON'T PUT HIM IN. THE A
PROBLEM TO SO THE NUMBERS HAVE
TO WAKE UP AND SAY KNOW THERE'S
GOING TO BE A LAW BIT OF AN TO
GO THERE DRIVING NIGHT. IF YOU
WANT HAVE THE PRISTINE. PLAN
YOUR DOCTOR. THERE IS SOME
INCONVENIENCE. SO DON'T TELL US
THAT WE'VE HAD HIM DO IT RIGHT
HERE MANAGER STATE WELL NOT MY
COUNTY BUT WE'LL PUT IT OVER
THERE IN THAT COUNTY AND
USUALLY WE REPRESENT RURAL
AREAS YOU GET TO BE THE DUMPED
ON COUNTY. EVERYBODY HAS GOT TO
TAKE SOME RESPONSIBILITY HERE
AND I'M HAPPY TO WORK WITH THE
CHAIR TO A DISSENSION I BELIEVE
WE ARE INDEED ON THE SAME PAGE.
I DO AGREE WITH YOU SENATOR
NIELSEN I AM. EVERYBODY WANTS
AFFORDABLE HOUSING JUST NOT IN
THEIR BACKYARD WHAT I TELL
PEOPLE IS YOU KNOW. THOSE
PEOPLE THAT YOU DON'T WANT
THIRTY HERE THEY JUST NEED A
PLACE TO LIVE AND THEY NEED TO
THEY NEED A PLACE THAT'S A SAFE
AND AFFORDABLE. AND- HIGH
QUALITY SO APPRECIATE THAT THAT
COMMENT SOMETHING. I IT DID I
FORGET THE L. A. O. LET ME SEE
IF THE L. A. O. HAS A COMMENT
ON THIS ONE. THANK YOU CHAIR-
AS NOTED IN THE GENDER FOR THE
IG PROGRAM THERE WERE JANUARY
PROPOSALS AS WELL AS THIS NEW
SPRING PROPOSAL AND SO WE ALSO
HAVE QUESTIONS ABOUT HOW THEY
ALL INTERACT AND- AS ALSO NOTED
THE- YOU KNOW REVENUE. PICTURE
WILL CHANGE THE ME REVISIONS
HOLDING ACTION TO WE HAVE A
BETTER SENSE OF HOW MUCH FUNDS
AVAILABLE THAT THE LEGISLATURE
MIGHT WANT TO DEDICATE TOWARDS
PAGES. IS A VERY REASONABLE
APPROACHAT THIS POINT THANK
YOU FOR THAT I DO APPRECIATE
THAT AND I ALSO WANT TO ADD. AS
A AS A FOOTNOTE TO THE AYE AYE
G. PROGRAM IS THAT TOM IS A
REALLY IMPORTANT PROGRAM THIS
IS THE ONE THAT PROVIDES
INFRASTRUCTURE TO BUILD
HOUSING. AND AS WE KNOW THE
INFRASTRUCTURE COSTS CAN BE
FORMIDABLE IN BRO. CALIFORNIA
BECAUSE YOU'RE TRYING TO. RIGHT
NOT PERTINENT TO BUILD HOUSING
SOME AREAS THAT- DON'T HAVE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE IN ORDER TO DO
IT. HAVING SAID THAT- THE IG
PROGRAM HAS DISPROPORTIONATELY
BEEN USED IN THE BIG CITIES.
AND SO ON IT'S IMPORTANT TO ME
TO EITHER HAVE A CARVE OUT.
WHERE RURAL CALIFORNIA IS
GUARANTEED SOME FUNDING. AND WE
DON'T HAVE TO COMPETE WITH THE
BIG CITIES LIKE SAN FRANCISCO
AND LA. AND OAKLAND IN AND UP.
IN OTHER COMMUNITIES OR- WHERE
THERE IS A- THE RULES ARE
WRITTEN IN A WAY THAT ALLOWS
RURAL CALIFORNIA'S TO PROTECT
CALIFORNIA'S CITIES TO COMPETE.
BUT NEVER NUMBER OF COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE BUILDING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND WHAT THEY NEED. IS
SEWER LINES. REPLACED BECAUSE
THEY'RE OLD AND OUTDATED NEVER
INTENDED FOR THE ADDITIONAL
RESIDENTS. THAT NEED. WATER
SYSTEMS UPGRADED. ROADS ALL THE
KINDS OF INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
THIS PRODUCT THIS FUND WOULD
WOULD- WOULD WOULD- DEAL WITH.
AND I'D LIKE TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'VE GOT SOME LANGUAGE IN
THERE PRODUCTORA CALIFORNIA.
THE BROWNFIELD LANGUAGE. WILL
MOSTLY GOING TO BIG CITIES- WE
DON'T HAVE BEEN BROWN FELS. IN
IN RURAL CALIFORNIA. IT'S
CALLED INDUSTRIAL SITES AND SO-
I WANNA MAKE SURE THAT THIS
PLACE FARE AND SO. THIS IS A-
HOLDO OPEN ITEM. AND I AM GOING
TO MAKE SURE THAT WHEN IT COMES
BACK IT COMES BACK IN A FORM
THAT THAT I CAN SUPPORT AS AT A
RURAL. REPRESENTATIVE AND I
KNOW SENATOR NELSON'S GOING TO
BE JUST AS CONCERNED ABOUT
THAT. THAT AS WELL. SO- WE WILL
NOW MOVE ON TO THE PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION PART OF THE
MEETING. REGARDING THE ITEMS
THAT ARE ON THIS AGENDA I WANT
TO REMIND YOU THAT TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
877-226-8150 TWO AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS TWO OH THREE. ONE EIGHT
ONE ZERO. DUE TO CONSTRAINTS
REGARDING THE LENGTH OF HEARING
TECHNOLOGY CONSIDERATIONS AND
CLEANING PROTOCOLS COMMITTEE
CHAIRS ME INSTITUTE TIME LIMITS
ON TESTIMONY TODAY I'M GOING TO
ASK THAT EACH MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC PROVIDING COMMENTS KEEP
THEIR REMARKS WITHIN ONE
MINUTE. AND NOW WE'RE GOING TO
BEGIN WITH. WE'LL START TO SEE
IF THEY'RE ANY WITNESSES HERE
IN THE HEARING ROOM AND I DON'T
SEE ANYONE. ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
WHO WISH TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT. THERE IS NOBODY THERE.
THANK YOU AND NOW WILL MOVE ON
TO THE WITNESSES WAITING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT VIA THE
TELEPHONE TELECONFERENCE ORVIS
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT WE CAN
BEGIN. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT ON TODAY'S CALL
THE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. OUR FIRST COMMENT
COMES FROM ONE THIRTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS CHEN REPORT
ON BEHALF OF THE CORPORATION
FOR SUPPORTIVE HOUSING AND THE
STEINBERG INSTITUTE WHERE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE PROPOSAL
UNDER ISSUE NUMBER FIVE WE'RE
GOING TO YEAR TWENTY BILLION
DOLLAR INVESTMENT TOWARDS
SOLVING HOMELESSNESS. WE URGE
THE COMMITTEE TO INCORPORATE
THE PROVISIONS OF THE BRING
ALLOCATIONS TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. IN CALIFORNIA HOME
IS A COALITION OF THREE HUNDRED
PLUS ORGANIZATIONS AND PEOPLE
WERE QUICK TO EXPERIENCE. AFTER
THE COMPREHENSIVE CONSENSUS
PROPOSAL ON RESTRUCTURING THE
STATE'S RESPONSE TO
HOMELESSNESS. EVEN THOUGH
VOTERS WAS THOMAS SMITH AS ONE
OF THE MOST CRITICAL ISSUES
FACING THE STATE THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
AND THE STATE AUDITOR HAVE
CHARACTERIZED THE STATE'S
RESPONSE ATTRACT MINTED AND
OFTEN INEFFECTIVE. BRING
CALIFORNIA HOME IT ENSURING
ACCOUNTABILITY LOCAL
COLLABORATION EQUITY AND STATE
AND LOCAL PARTNERSHIP DID
DRESSES CHALLENGES BUT THE HOME
OF COORDINATING AND FINANCING
COUNCIL IDENTIFIED WITH HALF.
IN INCLUDES REQUIRE ONSTATE
AGENCIES TO COORDINATE. AND
PROVIDES A DATA DRIVEN STATE
AND LOCAL DECISIONS ON HOW TO
USE FUNDING. EXPERIENCE SHOWS
US THAT STEADY PROGRESS IS ONLY
POSSIBLE WHEN GOVERNMENT'S
PLANNED WELL FUNDS EFFICIENTLY
AND TRACK OUTCOMES
CONSISTENTLY. YOUR PROPOSAL
OFFERS A UNIQUE OPPORTUNITY TO
BUILD ON PAST SUCCESSES AND
PRISCILLA BOB HOPE STRAT
STRATEGIC STATEWIDE STRATEGY
TOWARD SOLVING HOMELESSNESS. WE
HOPE BRING CALIFORNIA HOME I
CAN BE A PART AT THAT
OPPORTUNITY THANK OU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE.
FIND TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH GOOD
AFTERNOON CAN MINUTES
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR YOUTH WHEN I
THINK ABOUT IT BUT THEY'RE BOTH
PACKAGE AROUND HOMELESS. MAN
BEEN REALLY ENCOURAGE YOU TO
ENSURE THAT THEIR CREDIT BY
YOUNG PEOPLE TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY GET. IN OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITY AT THE BACK AND HOME
OF THE COOK PARTNER YANG PEOPLE
BECAUSE THEY DON'T GROW UP AND
THE HOMELESS MAN. AND WE'RE
VERY SUPPORTIVE OF A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS BUT UNDER THE
WINNER HAVE BEEN ADVOCATING FOR
TO ENSURE THAT WE BUILD HOUSING-
WHETHER EGGMAN BE SOMETHING
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING FOR
PREGNANT HOUSING FOR A YOUNG
PEOPLE AS WELL AS THE FACT IT
BY DEVELOPING. A HUNDRED
MILLION AND EPIDERMAL- BUT OUR
YOUNG PEOPLE AND IN THE PACKAGE
THAT WE CAN REALLY ADDRESS THE
GROWING ISSUE THE PROBLEM.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY. MUCH
NEXT PLEASE. MY YOUR LONG IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I THANK
YOU THIS IS CHERYL AND ADAM THE
CRICKET DIRECTOR LIKE THE YOU
THIRD ENCAMPMENTS CISCO AND I'M
OF CALIBER COAST FOR YOUTH
BORING HERE TO BE CONSTRUCTED
RARE FOR IDENTIFY AND FIND
ISSUE FIVE- WITH THE ADDITIONAL
REQUESTS THAT WE THINK AT LEAST
A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS FOR
YOUNG PEOPLE- YOUNG PEOPLE ARE
OFTEN INVISIBLE ON THE
HOMELESSNESS POPULATION. AND WE
KNOW THAT BY ADDRESSING THE
NEEDS OF YOUNG PEOPLE WHO ARE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS WE
GOT A LONG WAY IN ADDRESSING
AND PREVENTING LONG TERM
CHRONIC ADULT HOMELESSNESS-
ALSO WENT STRONG SUPPORT AND
SENATOR WIENER'S BILL FOUR
HUNDRED BILLION DOLLARS. IN
INFRASTRUCTURE TO TARGET
HOUSING AND SHELTER CREEK THE
HOUSING AND SHELTER FOR YOUNG
PEOPLE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU. NEXT PLEASE. MINDS
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI I'M ADAM BOOKBINDER
CAPITAL REPRESENTING ABOUT THE
UNIQUENESS QUICKLY SHOOT EIGHT
HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT.
NINE TWENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON COMMITTEE MEMBER ALEX
THE SAKE WITH THE LOS ANGELES
HOMELESS SERVICES AUTHORITY
WERE A PROUD MEMBER OF THE
BRING CALIFORNIA HOME COALITION
OUT. ITEM I WILL SUPPORT THE
SENATE'S PROPOSAL TO SPEND
TWENTY BILLION DOLLARS OVER
FIVE YEARS ON HOMELESSNESS AND
WE SUPPORT USING THE BRING
CALIFORNIA ON PROPOSAL AB
SEVENTY ONE AS THE PROGRAMMATIC
FRAMEWORK TO FUND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. THAT REMARK
INCLUDES- INNOVATIVE STRONG
ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES TO
ADDRESS A LOT OF THE THINGS
THAT THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
TALKED ABOUT TODAY AND ENSURE
THAT THIS MONEY IS REALLY
RESULTING IN. REDUCTIONS IN
HOMELESSNESS. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU. NEXT PLEASE.
MIND TWO YOUR IS OPEN THE BILL
HAS. YES I HAVE SENDING SOME
TOP RETURNING INDIRECTION AND
NOTES OF BERGERON. THERE TO
SUPPORT OUR THE NUMBER EIGHT
THE HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY. ACT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT PLEASE.
NINE ELEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I BROKEN
COALITION FOR SAN FRANCISCO
NEIGHBORHOODS IN OPPOSITION TO
HCD ISSUE NUMBER EIGHT. AND THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PRESSURE HIM
A FRIEND TO A NEW HOUSING
ACCOUNTABILITY IN UNIT TO
MONITOR AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
THERE WAS NO MENTION OF
ASSISTANCE THE HOUSING
ACCOUNTABILITY UNIT HAS NOW
BEEN REBRANDED AS A HOUSING
ASSISTANCE LAW. IN THE RUN UP
TO TWO EIGHT. THE TYPICAL COULD
MAKING COME- THE STATE'S
HOUSING NEEDS IN TWENTY TWENTY
THE GOVERNOR WALKED BACK IN THE
CAMPAIGN COMPANY NUMBER.
CALLING IT ASPIRATIONAL AND
THIS- THAT'S COOL NOW IN THE
RUN UP TO TWENTY TWENTY TWO THE
GOVERNOR HAS MADE PEOPLE CHANGE
YOUR PROPOSAL. THE COALITION
URGES USING A FOUR POINT THREE
MILLION TO ACTUALLY BUILD
AFFORDABLE HOUSING NOT CREATE
ANOTHER. LAYER OF BUREAUCRACY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT. ONE TWENTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SILAHKAN ELEVEN CHAIR NUMBERS
SINCE THE NINETEEN THAT CALLING
ON BEHALF OF. PLANNING AND
URBAN RESEARCH. HABITAT FOR
HUMANITY CALIFORNIA INFO ABOUT
THEM JAN HELP PROPERTY- AND PMG
PARTNERS AREN'T SUPPORT AS AN
ISSUE EIGHT CHIU PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO SUPPORT
FOR EACH ROLE IN PROVIDING
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
ENCOURAGEMENT- THAT- AT
ENFORCEMENT STATE HOUSING BONDS
AND BONDS THANK YOU VERY. MUCH
THANK YOU. NEXT. NINE THIRTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI TONY MARCIANO
CALLING FROM LOS ANGELES ON
BEHALF OF WHAT THAT FOR
EVERYONE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
ISSUE A HOUSING COUNT ABILITY
UNIT. THANKS THANK YOU NEXT
PLEASE. ONE SIXTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
MY NAME IS ERICA CALLING ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT
OF SHE RATE OF IN OUR SYSTEM
HAVING KIND OF A UNIT. THIS IS
A CRITICAL STEP TO ENSURE THAT
MANY OF THE- GREAT MARKET
RESEARCHER PASSED RECENT YEARS
AROUND EXCEPTIONAL BROWN UNIT.
HOUSING THE HOUSING ELEMENT
PROCESS AND HOUSING.
ACCOUNTABILITY ACT. PRACTICE.
TWO TO. MEETING THAT AND THAT
IS THE CASE WORSE ARE NOT
CORRECT- ONLY SMART OF THE
RESURGENT LIBERAL ARTS. CHANCE
FOR WAIT COMPANY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT PLAY.
ONE TWENTY FOUR YOUR IS OPEN GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON. ACTIVE
SERVICES AT THE SCIENCE THAT HE
CHARACTERS HELD WELFARE. THE
CODEPENDENT MAKE HAS
EXACERBATED THE HOMELESSNESS
CRISIS IN OUR STATE AND HAD A
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT ON SO
MANY OF THE CALIFORNIANS WHO
ARE LOW INCOME AGING OR
DISABILITY THE COUNTY WOMAN
SERVICES AGENCY SIR.
POPULATIONS WE SERVE COMPOSITE
THE CRACKS THE BROADER HOME PRO.
THE FUNDING AFFECT THEM THE
COUNTY CAN MARKS LIKE THE ME
THEIR LUCK NEEDS AS WELL AS-
NEED OF THE INDIVIDUAL CHRIS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT PLEASE. NINE THIRTY SEVEN.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS PAUL
RUBENSTEIN WHICH SAINT JOSEPH
CENTER IN VENICE BEACH SUPPORT.
I SENATE'S PROPOSAL AT TWENTY
BILLION OVER YEAR SPORT
PUBLISHED A SEPARATE. ALONG
WITH HUNDRED OF THE DARK SHE'S
UP BRAND CAL COALITION ARE ON
THE LINES WORKING SOLVE
PUBLISHERS IN OUR COMMUNITY DAY.
AFTER YOU CAN BE SUSTAIN OVER
TIME PARKS RESULTS. THE RING
CAL BACK WOULD PROVIDE YOU
STATED. STRONG ACCOUNTABILITY
MEASURES APPLIED PROVINCIALLY
SHINS. THANKS YOUR TIME TODAY
CHECK JUST- JUST. FOR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MUCH NEXT PLEASE.
MIND ONE YOUR IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME A EARNEST
WILL. AND I AM BE OF PROJECTS
AND SOCIAL AND- ABOUT FOR
COMMUNITY BILL IN CORE. AND WE
ARE OF THE CALIFORNIA HOME
BECAUSE- WITH OVER THREE
HUNDRED. WE CAN BUILDERS
SUPPORT OF THE SAN POWER TO
SPEND TWENTY DOLLAR OVER FIVE
YEARS OR- AND WE SHOULD USING
THE BRAIN CHILD HOME. THAT
PROGRAM AT THANK FOR FUNDING TO
LOOK GOVERNMENT WHICH- BRING
CALIFORNIA HOME TRYING INCLUDES
AN OF THE- STRONG
ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES TO FIND
PROGRAMS. TO HOMELESS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT PLEASE.
NINE THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
UP PLEASED AHEAD. I THANK YOU
MY NAME IS OAKLAND AND SHE WAS
AT LARKIN YOUTH SERVICES AND
FRANCISCO. I'M CALLING ON MY
SUPPORT THE ITEM NUMBER. AND-
URGE- THE OCCASION ASIDE
TRANSITION AGE YOUTH 20% I'D
LIKE KALRA THAT. YOUNG PEOPLE
ARE OFTEN INVISIBLE ABOUT HOW
MUCH OF SYSTEM AND DESIGNATING
FUNDING THAT MAY TO BE USED
TRANSITION YOUTH IT IS
ESSENTIAL. I'M NOT FOR THE AGE
OF TWENTY FIVE. ENDING YOUR
GOVERNMENT'S NASH REALLY IS A
CRITICAL STEP TOWARD ENDING AT
ALL THANK. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT PLEASE. LINE TWENTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS RYAN DO
LITTLE- I'M WITH OPERATION
CHECKS AND BALANCES A MEMBER OF
THE BRING HOME COALITION WHICH
INCLUDES OVER THREE HUNDRED
ENDORSERS WORKING TO SOLVE
HOMELESSNESS. WE ARE IN FULL
SUPPORT OF THE SENATE PROPOSAL
TO SPEND TWENTY BILLION OVER
FIVE YEARS FOR HOMELESSNESS AND
WE USED THAT WE SUPPORT IN THE
BRING HOME. IN CALIFORNIA HOME
PROPOSAL AS THE PROGRAMMATIC
FRAMEWORK FOR FUNDING. TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. THE B. C. H.
FRAMEWORK INCLUDE INNOVATIVE
STRONG ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES
TO FUND PROVEN SOLUTIONS TO
HOMELESSNESS. AREN'T REALLY
IMPORTANT AND THAT'S A BIG
PROBLEM AND- WOULD LOVE TO SEE
IT. SOME PROGRESS THANKS A LOT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT PLEASE.
NINE EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU FOR
OP TO COME MY NAME IS BOBO
NINE POLICY WITH THE A
NONPROFIT HOW NEWSROOM. OF
NORTHERN. I DON'T KNOW THAT.
PART OF THE CAL HOME COALITION
WHICH AND THE RITZ HUNDRED
STORES WORKING TO HOMELESSNESS
WITH THE PORT TWENTY BILLION
FIVE YEARS HOMELESS AND THE OF
THE BRING. HOME PROPOSED OF THE
PROBE FOR FUNDING LOCAL. BUT
NOT NUMBER SEVEN WE APPRECIATE
THE SENATE BOARD. SOLUTION
INCLUDE AND HOME AND STATE
THANK FROM ON IN THAT EVERYONE
A PLACE CALL HOME CURRENTLY IN
OUR- TEN AFFORDABLE SHOULD HAVE
RECEIVED FUNDING FROM THE STATE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH AND CAN.
TO AND ACTUALLY. AND READY TO
BE BUILT BUT I'VE BEEN YOU TO
FEDERAL RESTORE. A LOT OF
FEDERAL RESOURCE TO ACCELERATE
AND FUTURE APPEARS THE STATE
ARE REQUESTING TWENTY BILL
DOLLAR FROM THE AS AN INVESTOR
TO BUILD THE SHOP READY. MEDIA
WE. PROVIDE HOUSING UPPER. TO
THE MILLION OF CARP WHO BUT
PLACE TO LIVE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR- WITH. THANK YOU MUCH.
NEXT PLEASE. NINE FOUR FOUR
YOUR IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI THIS IS CHARLES HARM IN SAN
BRUNO I AM HERE SPEAK ON BEHALF
OF ENVIRONMENTAL WHICH EXISTS
TO ADDRESS THE CLIMATE
INEQUALITY CRISES BY
TRANSFORMING CITIES AND TOWNS
AND TO INCLUDES THE COMMUNITIES
DESIGNED AROUND PEOPLE RATHER
THAN CARS WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF
ITEM MAY BE A HOUSING LAWS AND
CAR HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY
GONNA THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH BUT A MODERATOR COULD YOU
TELL US HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE
CURRENTLY ON THE LINE. THERE
THEY WANT TO SPEAK. ARE WE HAVE
TWENTY ONE IN THE QUEUE OKAY
THANK YOU. NEXT PLEASE. NINE
FORTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT
TODAY MY NAME IS RACHEL ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR COMMUNITY
INVESTMENT A COALITION OF
CALIFORNIA BASED COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT FINANCIAL
INSTITUTION WE ARE PLEASED WITH
THE COMMITMENT IN THE PACKAGE
TO PROVIDE MORE RESOURCES FOR
ACQUISITION AND REHABILITATION.
WE WOULD LIKE TO URGE THAT THE
SENATE CONSIDER A BROAD
APPROACH TO THE STRATEGY OF
ACQUISITION AND REHAB. REPORTER
VARIETY OF HOUSING NEEDS IN
DOING FELT THE STATE SHOULD
ALLOCATE ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO
THE STATE VERY SUCCESSFUL
ACQUISITION REHAB PROGRAM THE
GOLDEN STATE ACQUISITION FIND
OR JEEP THAT. THE FUND IS
MANAGED AND ADMINISTERED BY A
CONSORTIUM OF SEVEN PDF FIVE
AND PROVIDE QUICK ACCESS TO
CAPITAL FOR ACQUISITION. OF
PROPERTY FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
AFFECTION THE FUND HAS TO BRING
MORE THAN TEN THOUSAND UNITS
AFFORDABLE RENTAL. AND LEVERAGE
MORE THAN. THREE AT HUNDRED AND
TWENTY ONE BILLION IN
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES FOR
HOUSING MORE THAN TEN TIMES
THEIR ORIGINAL INVESTMENT OF
TWENTY THREE MILLION. INCLUDES
ACQUIRING EXISTING HOUSING AND
CONVERTING IT OR PRESERVING IT
FOR THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
CURRENTLY THE PROGRAM
OVERSUBSCRIBED. OF THE LOOKED
TOWARD SUPPORTING ACQUISITION
REHAB WE WOULD URGE THE SENATE
TO INCLUDE THIS. ARE BITS ITEM
AT LEAST TWENTY FIVE MILLION IN
NEW FUNDING. FOR G. SAP THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT.
NINE FORTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS CERTAIN CRIMES ON
BEHALF OF THE PENINSULA YOU
YOUNG DEMOCRATS IN SENATE
DISTRICT THIRTEEN YOU'RE GOING
STRONG SUPPORT OF ISSUE EIGHT
THE HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY THAT
THE STATE HAS DONE A REALLY
ADMIRABLE JOB THE LAST TWO
YEARS AND CREATE A NEW LAW TO
ADDRESS THE HOUSING CRISIS. BUT
THE UNFORTUNATE REALITY REMAINS
THAT MANY STUDENTS ARE
UNWILLING TO COMPLY WITH.
ACCOUNTABILITY IS NEEDED AND
THAT'S WHAT THE STREET
ADDRESSES THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME. THE YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT PLEASE. NINE FORTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ON BEHALF OF GIVEN THE
ACTION AND YOU'LL BE LOCKED IN
STRONG SUPPORT I DIDN'T EAT- I
THINK IT AND SAID BUT I HOPE
YOU GUYS STAND BY THE WANT THE
PAST AND MITCHELL ENFORCING
THEM. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
PLEASE. NINE FORTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI HI MY NAME IS EMILY AND I'M
OPEN FROM THE CITY OF MOUNTAIN
VIEW IN REPRESENTING BACKING MD
INSTRUCTOR PART OF THE ISSUE
EIGHT THE HOUSING LAWS. THAT
BUT HOW DO I NEED TO GET MORE
NEIGHBORS THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU. NEXT PLEASE. ONE
FORTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
CHECK IT OUT AT I'M A FORMER
HOME MORPHINE AND PLYMOUTH ROCK
STREET- WHO IS CURRENTLY-
ACTUALLY- I DON'T THE TECHNICAL
CURRENTLY MY MECHANICAL
ABILITY- AND I'M CALLING IN OUR
SETTING ASIDE TIME BUT THE
EQUITY YOU PREVENT AND ADDRESS.
SOME BACK I AM A PART OF THE
PRINTOUT HOME AND- THE BUDGET
SHOULD REALLY HAVE ACCESS TO
THAT FUNDS BY THIRTY THAT
FOSTER CARE. BECAUSE THAT
SOMETHING. THAT THEY UNIQUE.
AND WE HAVE A SPECIAL MEETING
THE REQUIREMENT THAT I WOULD.
WATER THAT THANK YOU MUCH.
THANK YOU. EXPERTS MIND FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. RIGHT BACK ON THE LINE
IS ALFRED YOU WAIT THANK
EVERYONE AND WE'RE CALLING IN
OF BOTH THAT BRING TALENT HOME
AT RIGHT ITEM EIGHT YEAH
PROBABILITY UNIT. THANK YOU WE
BOTH OF THESE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT PLEASE. NINE FORTY A.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN GO OUT. HI MY
NAME IS A LINK TO MY AND I AM
CALLING REGARDING ISSUE NUMBER
FIVE TO ENCOURAGE INVESTMENT OF
EIGHTEEN POINT TWO MILLION
DOLLARS FOR. PREVENTING OR
REDUCING COSTING
ACCOMPLISHMENTS PROPOSAL WHICH
WILL PROVIDE IMPORTANT HOUSING
RESOURCES- FONG THANK YOU. AND
BRING HOMELESSNESS BEARING THE
PANDEMIC. RECOVERY THANK. THANK
YOU MUCH NEXT PLEASE. NINE
FIFTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IN THE LONG CORRECTLY
I'M HERE WITH JOHN BURTON
ADVOCATES FOR YOUTH PROVIDING
ISSUE FIVE URINE COURAGE IN
INVESTMENT OF EIGHTEEN POINT
TWO MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
PREVENTING AND REDUCING POVERTY.
THE PROPOSAL IT'LL PROVIDE
CRITICAL FUNDING DURING
PANDEMIC RECOVERY PERIOD
HELPING SUPPORT HER FORMER
FACTOR YOU COULD JUST.
EXPERIENCE HOMELESSNESS AND
REQUIRED APPROACH WHICH
MINISTER THIRD BACK MY TO UNDER
REGION WITH IMPACT OF THE
PENTAGON. WE FOUND THAT MORE
THAN ONE IN FIVE YOU COULD POUR
EXPERIENCING HOW MUCH IN THE
START OF THE PANDEMIC THEY WERE
ALSO MORE LIKE TO OUT OF. AND
LET LIKELY TO BE. THE PROPOSAL
WOULD MAKE THE EIGHT MILLION
DOLLAR TREE HOW PRO WHICH
PRIORITIZES FOX NEWS AND A FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR HOUSING
NAVIGATORS PROGRAM WHICH I
DON'T QUITE. AFTER YOU
PERMANENT PROGRAMS OPEN
MINISTER BY HDB THEY'RE
CRITICAL FOR COUNTY PANDEMIC
RESPONSE YOU COLLECT THAT
ALLOWING THEM TO OFFER A RANGE
OF SUPPORT THE POPULATION AND
ATTRACT TRADITIONAL HOUSING
WAIT LISTS THAT EXCEED FIVE
HUNDRED YOU THINK WHY WE URGE
HERE INCLUSION OF THIS
INVESTMENT. IN OUR STATE ARE
YOU. THANK VERY MUCH NEXT
PLEASE. FIND FORTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
PERHAPS KIMBERLY DE ON OF
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF ITEM EIGHT ADDITIONAL
FUNDING TO H. T. T. TO PROVIDE
LOCAL. AND ACCOUNTABILITY IN
YOUR HOUSE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXT PLEASE. NINE FIFTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS
MATT REGAN CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE DAY AREA COUNCIL AT THREE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MEMBER
EMPLOYER SPONSORED PUBLIC
POLICY GROUP IN THE SAN
FRANCISCO AREA- CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF ISSUE OKAY- THE
HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY I UNIT-
WE PASSED YOU HAVE PASSED BY
PROGRESSIVE BLOG RECENT YEARS.
BUT HOUSING PERMITS CONTINUE TO
FALL WE NEED ACCOUNTABILITY WE
NEED TO QUICKLY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NEXT PLEASE. ONE
TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
THAT IS JORDAN. A FORMER FOSTER
YOUTH AND CALLING ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA YOUTH CONNECTION
CALLING ON ISSUE FIVE EXPRESSED
SUPPORT FOR THE EIGHTEEN POINT
TWO MILLION DOLLARS IN
PREVENTING AND REDUCING FOSTER
YOUTH HOME RECORDS PROPOSAL
WHICH WILL PROVIDE CRITICAL
FUNDING DURING THE PANDEMIC
RECOVERY PERIOD FOR HELPING
SUPPORT FOR CURRENT AND FORMER.
CHIEF THAT DISPROPORTIONATELY
EXPERIENCE HOMELESSNESS AND
ALSO REQUIRE A TARGET APPROACH
I'M HISTORICALLY YOU HAVE BEEN
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED
DURING ECONOMIC DOWNTURNS AND
THE PANDEMIC HAS EXACERBATED
THE CROP AND TRIBULATIONS A
KERNEL FUNCTION YOU HAVE. JUST
ONE LIKE THE ECHO INDIVIDUALS
WITH WITH THE GRANT TO HAVE
SHARED THEIR TESTIMONY TO
PROVIDE SUPPORT FOR HAVE THE
BILL THANK. YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT PLEASE. NINE FIFTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU SO MUCH MY
NAME IS GAIL DONNAN WITH
BRINGING CALIFORNIA HOME
COALITION FROM OUR HOME HE
EIGHT WORKING NINE BAY AREA
COUNTIES YOU DISRUPT
HOMELESSNESS WE ARE IN SUPPORT
OF ITEM NUMBER FIVE IN THE
TWENTY BILLION DOLLAR
ALLOCATION AT THE STATE SENATE
IS REQUESTING. WE KNOW THAT
HOMELESSNESS HAS ONLY WORSENED
DURING THE PANDEMIC AND WE
REALLY BELIEVE THAT THE BRING
ME A HARM FRAMEWORK SHOULD BE
USED FOR THOSE FUN TO GET
JURISDICTIONS BUT LACKS ABILITY
AND THE ABILITY TO BE
ACCOUNTABLE. FOR POPULATION
LEVEL REDUCTION. HOPE THAT THE
WOMAN BIRDS AND- ALL HOME.
STRONGLY SUPPORTED I AM FIVE.
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. NINE
FIFTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO HOME. HI THERE AND
CAN YOUR COMMENTS WITH
OPERATION CHECKS AND BALANCES
ALSO AMENDMENT TO BRING HEALTH
CALIFORNIA HOME COALITION AND
I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT ITEM
NUMBER FIVE- WE'RE GOING TO PUT
IT THE SENATE PROPOSAL TO SPEND
OVER TWENTY BILLION OVER FIVE
YEARS FROM HOMELESSNESS. AT THE
CURRENT USING BRING CALIFORNIA
HOME PROPOSAL FOR FUNDING TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THE PCH
FRAMEWORK INCLUDES INNOVATIVE
STRONG ATTENTIVELY MEASURES TO
FIND PRISON CONDITIONS. DAHMER
THANK YOU. THE YOU NEXT PLEASE.
NINE FIFTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. JERRY
MEMBERS PROPOSAL JONATHAN FROM
ACROSS THE ROOM. I AM CALLING
TO SUPPORT THE PREVENTION FACT
SHEET I'M BUDGET AND GREEN
COLOR WHAT THE CONGRESSMAN
SATISFIED OF ON THANKS FOR
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. NINE
FIFTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI WORK WITH
IN THE ACTION EAST BAY- IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF EITHER MADE
THE HUSBAND PROCESS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT. ONE FIFTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS JAMES CARTER I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF FIRST THANK YOU ONE
OF THE LARGEST COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATION PROVIDING HOUSING
INDEPENDENT LIVING BENEFIT
YOUNG PEOPLE AGING OUT OF
FOSTER CARE I'M HERE TO EXPRESS
OUR STRONG SUPPORT OF EIGHTEEN
POINT TWO MILLION DOLLAR
PREVENTING. MAKING THINGS
FASTER YOU COMMENCEMENT
PROPOSAL AT THE PROVIDER FOR
THE POPULATION WE BE FIRSTHAND
THE DESPERATE NEED FOR MORE
HAVING THE FIRST THE COURT TO
ENSURE THAT YOU. CAN AND THE
PRESSURE THEIR FAITH AND JUST
INCREASED MUCH OF THE- WE KNOW
THAT THE NEW SURVEY HAS SHOWN
THAT ONE IN. FIVE ONE APATHETIC.
DURING THE PANDEMIC. THOSE ARE
HOUSE THIRTEEN ANYTHING
ECONOMIC AND I PROGRAM OVER OF
YOUNG LOST THEIR OR HOW THEIR
WORKING HOURS BEGINNING TO THE
PANDEMIC BUT WE REALLY BEEN
THAT PROPOSED BARBARA OULD
MAKE- PETER HOUSING FOR AND HOW
NOT PROGRAM COMING TO. LONG WAY
IN HELPING BRING HOMELESSNESS.
CREDIT POPULATION AFTER I BROKE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR MUCH
NEXT PLEASE. MY ANSWER TWO YOUR
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
SIXTY TWO YOUR IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON POPULAR BECAUSE OF
GLOBAL FACTOR CAL PROJECT TO
TALK OF THE PORTABLE HOW
PROVIDE EITHER THE BAY AREA
INSTRUCT THE PETITION NUMBER
FIVE HUNDRED PACKAGE TWENTY
BILLION OVER FIVE YEARS WE
STRONG SUPPORT THE OPPOSITION
WE HAVE CONCLUDED THE PACKAGE
BE LIKE I'M GOING. TO PROVIDE
ADEQUATE HOUSING FOR THOUSANDS
OF THOSE ENCAMPMENTS. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR KIND CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. NINE SIX
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS ANNA THOMPSON WITH JOHN
BURTON ADVOCATES FOR YOU DAVID
GRATEFUL FOR THE CURRENT SENATE
BUDGET PROPOSAL TO INVEST
TWENTY BILLION DOLLARS TO
PREVENT AND REDUCE AWKWARDNESS
AND I'M CALLING TO REQUEST A
MINIMUM OF 10% OF THE STATE.
BUDGET SPENDING ON HOMELESSNESS
INCLUDING ANY INVESTMENT IN
HALF EMPTY OR NEW PROGRAM
FUNDING BE DEDICATED TO
ATTRACTING HOMELESSNESS AMONG
YOUTH NOW MORE THAN EVER
HOMELESS YOUTH IN CALIFORNIA
REQUIRE ACCESS TO SAFE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING WHICH IS WHY
WE ARE ALSO. PUBLIC SPONSORED
OF THE BRING CALIFORNIA HOME
BUDGET REQUESTS IN AB THIRTY
ONE ARE YOU SATISFIED YOU WORK
ON WITHOUT A YOU BETTER THANK
YOU DOCTOR THERE ARE LOCAL
COMMERCENTRE. SYSTEM LESS THAN
1% OF COMPETE ENDING WINTER
FUNDING HELPING FOR YOU WHICH
MARILYN STORE ALL BLACK OF
SPENDING FROM THE FEDERAL
LEVEL- SO WE ARE JUST SO
THANKFUL AND WE HOPE THAT THE
SENATE MULTI YEAR INVESTMENT
GIVES US AN OPPORTUNITY TO
RECONSIDER HOW WE ADMINISTER
FUNDING INCLUDING HOW WE REACH
YOU AND WE URGE YOUR
CONCLUSION. OF YOU IF YOU'RE
SPENDING ON HOMELESSNESS YOU'RE
SATISFIED. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NEXT PLEASE. NINE SIX YOUR LONG
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
SIXTY YOU MAY BE ON MUTE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. WE'RE GOING TO
NINE SIXTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS DAVID I'M CALLING FROM
UNION CITY AND SENATE DISTRICT
TEN I WANTED TO BECOME A PART
OF. OUR ITEMS FIVE AND EIGHT
THE RIPPING CALIFORNIA HOMICIDE
HAVING ROCKS. IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT PEOPLE WITH OUR SON HOMES
TO BE BUILT AND MAKE SURE THAT
YOU ARE BUILDING THE HOMES THAT
THEY ARE PLANNING FOR IN A
HOUSING ELEMENT AND ALSO.
MAKING SURE BETTER NOT BREAKING
THE HOUSE LAW TO HELP MAKE SURE
THAT HOUSING APPROVAL CAN BE
MORE CONSISTENT AND STRAIGHT
LIKE THAT THAT. WE CAN GET
ACTUALLY GET MORE. PEOPLE
CONNECTED THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
BONTA MODERATOR HOW MANY DO WE
HAVE YET TO SPEAK. WE HAVE NINE
IN THE QUEUE. VERY GOOD NEXT
PLEASE. NINE SIXTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
SIXTY YEAR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS ALEXIS BERRY THE FORMER
BOXING BUT NOW YOU'VE GOT THE
KIDS I'M A COMPANY A PROVEN
SOLUTIONS WHICH INCLUDES THE
TECH OFFENSE I'D BUY THEM I.
THANK YOU FOR COMING
UNDERSUPPLY. THANK YOU.
EXPERTISE. ONE SIXTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS JASON
CHUNG CALLING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION. I'M
ALSO A HIGH SCHOOL STUDENT HIGH
SCHOOL SENIOR FROM CISCO- VALUE
ADVOCATE- SEVEN SUPPLY OF THE
PROPOSAL THE TWO BILLION OUT OF
FIVE- WITH THE SPECIFIC PERCENT.
FOR ONE- WORLD SUPPORT THE OF-
BUT REQUESTED BY THE COUNCIL.
WHAT WILL MANY OF ORGAN VERY TO
PROVIDE FROM THE POWER OF COACH
MUTE IN CALGARY YOU CONNECTION
TO STYLISH THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC CONNECTION A THREE POINT
FOUR MILLION DOLLAR GENERAL FOR
OPERATIONAL- APPARENTLY- WITH
EXPERIENCE IN THE PUBLIC YOU'RE
NOT A CUSTOMER FONG CARE WITH
ABILITY TO BETTER BY ON HOW.
BEST OUR TOP SHOULD BE SPENDING
ITS- BOND THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THE. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU NECK
PLEASE. NINE SIXTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN GO OUT. HI MY NAME
IS JEFF MCBRIDE I REPRESENT IN
THE AND THEY CAN'T FOR HOUSE
ELEMENT I LIVED TO TWENTY FOUR-
WE HAVE A RARE. TO PROVIDE
HOUSING FOR MANY MORE
CALIFORNIANS INCLUDING FACTORY
USE THAN HOMELESS AND
NEIGHBORS- THROUGH THE HOUSING
ELEMENT PROCESS AND WE CAN'T DO
THAT WITHOUT ACCOUNTABILITY AND
ENFORCEMENT. AND PRETEND IT
SHOCKED THE COURT OF ISSUE
EIGHT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
PLEASE. NINE SIXTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
LET THE FANS HAVE ON BEHALF OF
AT THE ARE YOU CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTING COUNTY SOCIAL
SERVICES WORKERS IN THE CHILD
WELFARE SERVICES ADULT
PROTECTIVE SERVICES AND ADULT
UTILITY SERVICE THOSE ARE
REUNITED IN STRONG SUPPORT. OF
THE SENATE. WELL ITEM NUMBER
TWO TWENTY BILL DOLLARS TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC THAT
PARTICULARLY AS IT RELATES TO
THE FLEXIBILITY TO ENSURE THAT
LOCAL GOVERNMENT EXPENDITURES
CAN BE EXPANDED ON THE PROGRAM
AREAS MOST IN NEED. WE ARE
THANK YOU MUCH. THANK YOU NEXT
PLEASE. NINE SIXTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS CHRISTINA TAURUS AND
I AM TWENTY FOUR YEARS OLD. AND
I AM A FORMER BOSS YOU AND I
HAVE EXPERIENCE OF THOMAS. I'M
CALLING REGARDING ISSUE NUMBER
FIVE DURING HURRICANE
INVESTMENT OF EIGHTEEN POINT
ZERO MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
FINANCING AND REDUCING FOSSIL
ALMOST APPROACH. WHICH WILL
PROVIDE IMPORT HOUSING
RESOURCES THAT ARE POSH
DIFFERENT FROM. ON THE BEARING
THE PANDEMIC RECOVERING. I HAVE
A THANK ALMOST TWELVE AT THE
TIME IN THE PAST THANK. AND
BELIEVE. IN HELPING FOX NEWS
SHE ABOUT. AND WHAT ARE. WHAT
PROPOSAL AND ALLOW US BOX TO
HAVE THAT THE BILL THAT THE
HOURS FROM AT FOR THE COURT THE.
IF YOU EIGHT HOUSING
ACCOUNTABILITY UNIT AND ALSO
SPEAKING PERSONALLY FOR MYSELF
I ALSO SUPPORT ISSUE FIVE
THANKS. THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT
PLEASE. NINE SEVENTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BOB I CAN'T REMEMBER I
SUPPORTERS SHOULD HAVE BEEN
KIND OF GOING IN AND PRETEND IN
A PERSONAL CAPACITY FOR THAT
ITEM FIVE. AND IF YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT PLEASE. NINE SEVENTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS ELIZABETH CRUZ A FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH CALLING FROM THE
INTER CALIFORNIA TO SUPPORT THE
PREVENTIVA POCKET HOMELESSNESS
BUDGET BRING CALIFORNIA HOME
WITH THE 10% YOU SATISFIED.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT PLEASE. ONE SEVENTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME'S BILL PARK
THE CONTRACT I CHECKED
CUPERTINO FOR ALL WHICH IS
HOUSING PROGRAMS ORGANIZATION
BASED IN CUPERTINO I'M I'M- ONE
OF DIDN'T EIGHT I THINK IT IS
SO IMPORTANT THAT WE HAVE
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR STUDENTS- I
CONSTANTLY. MY CITY WHERE I
GREW UP IN THE LOGS AND I'M NOT
THE KIND OF IT WILL. NUMBER
ABLE TO ACTUALLY. STRONG
APPARATUS FOR KEEPING KEEPING
TRACK THANKS MUCH. THANK YOU
NEXT. OUR FINAL COMMENT COMES
FROM NINE SEVENTY SIX POINT
SEVENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS SUE EVAN SOMEONE FAMILY
SERVICES A TRANSITIONAL HOUSING
PROGRAM IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
I AM CALLING TO EXPRESS SUPPORT
FOR ISSUE NUMBER FIVE. AND THE
EIGHTEEN POINT TWO MILLION
PREVENTIVA KEEPING PARKING.
PERMIT THE PROPOSAL. IF YOU
CURRENTLY PROVIDE WILL HAVE FOR
THE BY FROM IS WE ARE A TO
PROVIDE AND SIGNIFICANT HOUSING
AND DISPELLING STEPHANIE
NEEDED. TO HELP SUPPORT SOME OF
THE MOST VULNERABLE HOUSTON TO
FIVE G. WELL I APPRECIATE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY AND-
TO INCLUSION AT THE TEN BEST
ENOUGH THANK. YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE DID HAVE
ONE LAST COMMENT IN THE QUEUE
THANKS. I'M SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS BRIAN PRESS KIT
I'M CALLING FROM SAN JOSE
CALIFORNIA I'M A MEMBER OF
SOUTH BAY UNITY I'M CALLING TO
EXPRESS MY SUPPORT FOR ISSUE
EIGHT THANK YOU. THANK YOU- NO
FURTHER COMMENTS THANK YOU.
VERY GOOD THAT CONCLUDES OUR
THE PUBLIC COMMENT PORTION OF
OUR AGENDA AND SO WE'RE WE'RE
READY TO MOVE ON TO OUR VOTE
ONLY ITEMS IF WE COULD JUST
TAKE A MINUTE WILL AND MAKE
SURE WORLD. HERE AND WE CAN GO
THROUGH THIS ONE TIME. JUST
TAKE A MINUTE OR SO.
CAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE WE'VE
HEARD FROM ALL OF THE PUBLIC
AND I WANT TO THANK THEM FOR
THEIR TESTIMONY HERE TODAY AND
THEIR PATIENTS ON THE LINE AND
I REALLY DO APPRECIATE. THE
PUBLIC BEING INVOLVED IN OUR-
IN OUR IN OUR HEARINGS AND SO-
I WANT TO SEE IF CENTERS HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS THEY
WANT TO MAKE. SAYING THEN WE'RE
GONNA MOVE ON TO. WE'RE GOING
TO TAKE ACTION ON THE BOAT ON
LAKE ITEMS WHICH WILL BE ISSUES
ONE THROUGH FOUR. FOLLOWED BY
ISSUES EIGHT AND NINE AND WE'RE
SO WE'RE GONNA TAKE THE VOTES
WANTED TIME TO HAVE A MOTION ON
THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION FOR
ISSUE NUMBER ONE. OPR
ADMINISTRATIVE STAFF
AUGMENTATION. MOTION MOTION BY-
SENATOR KAMLAGER- PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. CABALLERO HI NIELSEN
ON WATER I. THREE GOOD MOVING
ON TO THAT MOTION CARRIES TWO
EYES ONE NO. ABOUT MOVING ON TO
ISSUE NUMBER TWO- THAT'S THE
JUST TRANSITION ROAD MAP AND I
HAVE PULLED THAT FOR EIGHTY UP
SEPARATE DISCUSSION ADDED AT A
LATER DATE SO WE'RE GONNA MOVE
ON TO ISSUE NUMBER THREE WHICH
IS THE REGIONAL CLIMATE
COLLABORATIVE. PROGRAM IS THERE
A MOTION ON THAT ISSUE.
KAMLAGER MAKES A MOTION- PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. CABALLERO I
NIELSEN. KAMLAGER I XIN KERRY'S
EYES TO NOSE THIS ONE MOVING ON
TO ITEM NUMBER FOR ISSUE NUMBER
FOUR. WHICH IS THE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE ALLOCATION IS THERE
A MOTION. CENTER COMMAGER-
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL AT A YEAR
I ILSAN COBBLER I MOTION PASSES
THREE EYES NOSE. ZERO MOVING ON.
TO ISSUE ISSUE NUMBER EIGHT I
BELIEVE IS THAT. THE C. TEN
FIFTEEN. HE NEED EMOTIONAL MATH.
THE MOTION IS MADE BY THIRTY
NIELSEN YOU MAKE THAT MOTION.
OKAY OF WILL HAVE A SENATOR
KAMLAGER MAKE THE MOTION THEN-
YES PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ZERO
FIVE NIELSEN KAMLAGER HI MOTION
PASSES IS TO. KNOWS ONE AND ON
TO THE LAST ITEM WHICH IS. FOR
THAT ITEM THAT'S CORRECT THAT
ITEM WE'RE GONNA LEAVE OPEN SO
THAT CONCLUDES OUR AGENDA FOR
TODAY. NUMBER EIGHT SUPPORT FOR.
UNDERSTOOD COMPLETELY AND IT
WILL BE SO NOTED FOR THE RECORD
CENTER. THANK YOU SO MUCH. THAT
CONCLUDES OUR BOB THE HEARING
ON THE SENATE BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEW. SUB FOR THANK YOU ALL
VERY MUCH FOR JOINING US HERE
TODAY IF YOU HAVE ANY COMMENTS
OR CONCERNS YOU CAN PLEASE SEND
THEM INTO THE- SENATE.
COMMITTEE BUDGET COMMITTEE AND
THEY'LL BE- WE WOULD APPRECIATE
THOSE COMMENTS AND THE BE-
TAKEN SERIOUSLY SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR ATTENTION
TODAY.